hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner welt heute
gibt es wieder einen teil von salis
classics ich werde heute einen
russischen zupfkuchen machen
da wurde ich wirklich schon ganz oft
danach gefragt ob ich nicht mal das
rezept veröffentlichen würde
das mache ich gleich und dazu zeige ich
euch jetzt einmal die zutaten wir
brauchen 350 gramm mehl 200 g weiche
butter 150 gramm zucker 130 gramm
kakaopulver eine packung backpulver und
eine prise salz
die ist dann heute die zutaten reichen
für eine form mit dem durchmesser von 32
zentimetern
ich habe jetzt die hier da könnt ihr
wirklich jeder andere auch benutzen
die werde ich jetzt einmal noch vorher
vettel damit eben später der kuchen
nicht drin kleben bleibt falls ihr jetzt
aber keine 32er form habt ganz viel
nebel dann könnt ihr auch eine kleine
reform nehmen
ich habe euch ja beim double cheesecake
video eine umrechnung tabelle auf meinem
blog gestellt da könnt ihr dann einfach
die mengen um rechnen also wenn ihr
jetzt zum beispiel sagt ich habe nur
eine 28er form geht ihr auf diese
tabelle und könnte es dann ablesen da
gibt's dann der umrechnung zahl da ist
es vielleicht nur das problem mit dem
aber wahrnehmen da einfach auch eine
also das macht jetzt nicht ob da jetzt
dann irgendwie drei viertel heraus kommt
nimmt dann einfach hinein
jetzt habe ich einen fingerabdruck naja
egal die form werde ich jetzt noch
wählen damit auch wirklich nichts dran
klebt super stadt ist gemacht die form
kann ich jetzt einfach kurz zur seite
stellen und weil jetzt gleich den teig
vorbereiten
ich werde den tag geht es in meiner
kitchenaid zu bereiten falls er keine
küchenmaschine habt könnt ihr das ganze
aber auch per hand verkneten oder ihr
nehmt ein handgerät oder ihr nehmt den
thermomix also der kinder wirklich jede
küchenmaschine nehmen oder auch keine
küchenmaschine sind dateien schnell
gemacht dass ich ein all-in teig das
heißt alle zutaten kommen einfach in den
topf werden verrührt und dann ist der
teig auch schon fertig jetzt kommen
einfach nacheinander alle zutaten in die
rührschüssel
und zum schluss noch die butter und
jetzt weder teig so lange gerührt bis
eine homogene masse ist also bis alles
zu einem glatten teig verrührt ist und
dann ist der teig auch schon fertig er
zeigt sieht dann so aus als es ist schon
so ein typ der aber etwas weicher ist
jetzt nehmt ihr euch hier von einem
viertel und lenkt ist weg das ist bei
mir jetzt so etwa eine handvoll also
soviel lege ich jetzt weg
das brauchen wir dann nämlich später für
obendrauf für diesen tipp kuchen eben
das werde dann später drauf gezupft du
darfst heute keinen thailand den brauch
ich okay du darfst und mit dem
restlichen teig werden jetzt die form
auskleiden und den leg dir da einfach
rein und könnt euch jetzt erstmal so
einen kleinen rand formen
daran sollte bis hoch geben meine form
hat etwa sondern 5 cm hohen rand und da
gucke ich dass ich bis fast hochgehen
es muss hier auch nicht ganz sorgfältig
aussehen ich find es bei den kuchen
immer ganz schön wenn der rand etwas
ungleichmäßig ist
und den rest zerdrückt ihr jetzt einfach
mit der hand schöner boden entlang
und wenn ihr das dann soweit habt könnt
ihr den kuchen so lang kalt stellen und
den teig könnte auch kalt stellen
ich werde euch jetzt nämlich nochmal die
zutaten für die füllung zeigen und zeigt
euch wie man sie zubereitet
wir brauchen drei eier 150 gramm zucker
500 gramm quark 200 gramm sahne 1
esslöffel vanillezucker 70 g weiche
butter 25 gramm speisestärke und auch
hier ist noch eine prise salz mit dabei
und da können sie ganz einfach die alte
schüssel wieder nehmen das bisher zeigt
das macht nichts und jetzt kommen hier
auch wieder alle zutaten rein und werden
einmal gemeinsam verrührt und hier ganz
besonders wichtig dass die butter ganz
weich oder fast schlüssig ist weil sie
sich eben sonst nicht gut vermengt und
ihren klümpchen bekommt
das ganze frühere ich jetzt erst bei
niedriger stufe und dann einmal richtig
bei höchster stufe und dann ist die
füllung auch fertig
ich bin jetzt bis etwa stufe 8 gegangen
bei stufe 10 sprit nämlich alles raus
die fertige füllung könnte jetzt ganz
einfach hier ein film und hier seht ihr
jetzt auch dass der rand viel höher ist
als die füllung das muss aber so sein
weil er der tour kuchen noch in die höhe
geht jetzt nehmt ihr euch ganz einfach
den restlichen teig und zupft den ebenso
hier drüber bei dem zug kochen ist nicht
ganz bekannt wo hat er überhaupt kommt
ich dachte immer da kommt eben aus
russland war dieser russischer
zupfkuchen heißt da habe ich jetzt mal
nachgeforscht und es ist irgendwie
umstritten ob der aus der ukraine kommt
oder aus der türkei hat mich auch sehr
verwundert
vielleicht weiß es jemand von euch
besser dann würde ich mich freuen wenn
ihr mir das mal in die kommentare
schreibt
ich finde es nicht immer ganz schön zu
wissen eben wo die sachen dann auch
herkommen was der ursprung ist ja jetzt
ist der kuchen kommt jetzt bei 180 grad
für etwa 60 minuten in den ofen
ich werde ihnen danach dann natürlich
euch zeigen und ihr müsst da auch darauf
achten dass der ofen natürlich
vorgeheizt ist und ich werde das ganze
bei ober und unterhitze backen kuchen
bereits eine stunde im ofen und ich habe
jetzt auch noch mal 15 minuten abkühlen
lassen
dafür habe ich dass der kuchen auch mit
einem tuch abgedeckt und jetzt werde ich
hier mit einem messer am rand ein
bisschen entlang fahren damit der kuchen
sich ganz leicht löst es geht ja auch
sehr einfach weil wir ja die formschönen
eingefettet hatten
aber ich mache das immer mal noch ganz
gerne noch mal sicher zu gehen und jetzt
setze ich meinen kuchen auf so eine
kleine form drauf bei meinem springform
rand ist nämlich so ich kann denn jetzt
öffnen und muss dann von oben raus heben
und so geht es eben einfacher
und jetzt kann ich hier ganz einfach mit
einem torten retter unter die platte
gehen also unter dem kuchen und kann ihn
auf die platte setzen dann da den spring
vom rand und den spring vom boden
wegnehmen und so sieht jetzt der fertige
russischer zupfkuchen aus ich werde
jetzt noch nicht anschneiden und kann
ihn nicht probieren weil er noch warm
ist
außerdem nehme ich ihn mit meiner
freundin ihr könnt da jetzt natürlich
noch etwas puderzucker drüber schreiben
den kuchen kann man auch wirklich ein
paar tage lang essen das ist ein richtig
schöner feuchter käsekuchen mit schoko
geschmack ihr könnt ein kuchen natürlich
auch in einer kleineren form packen und
dafür schaut eben wie gesagt auf meinem
blog vorbei ich verlinke euch natürlich
den link mit dieser umrechnung tabelle
noch mal in meiner infobox hier unten
for information wo info steht und dieses
rezept werde ich euch auch auf meinem
blog veröffentlichen
dazu schaut ihr auch bitte unten in der
infobox nach ich wünsche euch auf jeden
fall ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken ich
finde den kuchen zu lecker ich kann ihn
mir auch ganz super mit etwas zitrone
vorstellen in erfüllung
und ich freue mich natürlich auf eure
kommentare und auf eure bewertungen
teilt das video wenn es euch gefällt und
dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder
bis bald und im anschluss verlinke ich
euch jetzt gleich noch mal zwei andere
videos einmal den anderen classic kuchen
die linzer torte und einmal einen double
cheesecake der aussah lecker ist und
morgen werde ich übrigens noch ein video
hochladen im verbraucherbildung da freue
ich mich auch ganz arg drüber und bin
schon gespannt was ihr dazu sagt